thank you
as DC Young Fly navigates his grief
following Miss Jackie O's death he's
remembering her as the greatest mother
to their children and I got her name say
to what my phone is Queen
oh the Wild and out star shares an
emotional tribute to Instagram one week
after his longtime partner died at just
32 years old speaking of Jackie in the
message DC Praises how she always wanted
the best for others and Promises to tell
their three kids Nova Nala and Prince
Nehemiah what an amazing person she was
happy birthday is July 25th
any other fun facts about him
what's your favorite thing about him
I like his favorite thing
you love his fat cheeks yes
teach them everything I know amits her
family's tragedy DC says we'll continue
to pray and hold on to our faith echoing
many of his condolences in the comments
one of them from Kiki Palmer who assures
DC quote God has you and your babies
I feel like we're so rushed even though
we had all the time DC also explains
that he's waited until now to speak out
because he's still processing life
without Jackie TMZ reported that the TV
personality died in Miami but there's
still no official details about her
cause of death
a round of applause
Jackie and D C met in 2015 the
made his first appearance on wild 'n out
I'm a bit of a rebel when it comes to
this because I'm a vet so I don't really
do
bet Media Group confirmed her death last
week in a tribute calling Jackie O a
loving friend and beloved colleague of
the show's cast for Five Seasons and
saying her impact will be forever
treasured and missed
[Music]